ils sont américains démocrates et étudie
tous les quatre à l'université mcgill
cet automne pour la première fois de
leur vie ils votent pour choisir leur
président c'est le fun ses côtés dans la
démocratie
je pense que c'est important que tout le
monde veut participer à ça parce que on
a le pouvoir de changer hasard
maya elle a déjà envoyé son bulletin de
vote au colorado
son dernier lieu de résidence aux états
unis c'est là qu'il sera comptabilisé
brent aussi a déjà voté
j'ai peur nous n'avons jamais eu un
président comme ça dit il
il refuse de promettre une transition
pacifique s'il perd et discréditent sans
arrêt elle vote par la poste
les récentes compressions dans le
système postal et le manque d'employés
en période de pandémie ne rassure pas
les américains à l'étranger
andy white ne le dirige la branche
montréalaise de l'organisme democrats
abroad dès janvier elle a commencé à
guider ses 2500 membres dans leurs
démarches pour voter à l'extérieur des
états unis c'est au canada que vivent le
plus grand nombre d'américains et de
loin
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle en 2016
ils étaient six cent vingt deux mille
ici à pouvoir voter
mais à peine plus de 5 % l'avait fait
les choses s'annoncent bien différente
cette année
d'un côté les démocrates semblent bien
mobilisés pour défaire donald trump le
nombre de nos membres qui ont dit avoir
voté ou qui veulent voter a doublé voire
triplé dans le monde d'hier andy white
non l'organisation compte d'ailleurs 50%
plus de membres depuis un an à montréal
les républicains quant à eux se font
plus discrets dans son salon d'ottawa
georgian burke a installé des affiches
pro trempe fabriqués au canada dit elle
avec fierté
c'est une des rares à avoir accepté de
nous parler ce n'est pas agréable d'être
une républicaine au canada ces jours ci
je me suis fait traiter de nazi de
misogyne d'homophobe et de raciste on
m'a même dit de retourner aux états unis
elle croit que plusieurs évite de dire
qu'ils vont voter pour donald rend les
réalisations avant le style
même son cloche chez cet avocat de
calgary regardez ces accomplissements
les taxes sont à leur plus bas de
l'histoire du pays et l'économie était
la plus forte de la planète avant le
coronavirus résume alexander marino qui
a déjà voté lui aussi mais qu'ils soient
républicains ou démocrates ils
s'entendent au moins sur une chose leur
pays d'origine
plus divisé que jamais traverse une
crise j'ai peur pour le futur qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour le travail pour
tous parce que moi en ce moment que
c'est chez pas aussi après ma graduation
fait un peu leur rester au canada
le 4 novembre nous serons toujours
américain est tous dans le même bateau
les deux ont fait appel à l'unité à
quelques jours d'une soirée qui sera
sans doute suivi avec nervosité partout
au canada
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal